le gros plus haut tu as déposé dans son
créneau une proposition de loi visant à
l'abrogation du recul de l'âge de départ
à la retraite et à la création d'une
conférence de financement du système de
retraite
cette proposition de loi a été déclarée
recevable par le Bureau de l'Assemblée
nationale et a été inscrit le 8 juin à
l'ordre du jour de notre assemblée
ce matin
le président de la commission des
finances saisie par la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales là
également déclaré recevable certaines
rumeurs madame la Première ministre
selon lesquels le gouvernement pourrait
être avoir recours au vote bloqué de
l'article 44 3 de la Constitution
d'autres rumeurs évoquent une éventuelle
nouvelle réunion du bureau de
l'Assemblée nationale pour écarter cette
proposition le gouvernement
laissera-t-il l'Assemblée nationale se
prononçait sur cette proposition de loi
ou aura-t-il de nouveaux recours à des
dispositions visant à en empêcher le
vote
vous qui depuis maintenant plusieurs
décennies bataillées sur les projets de
loi de finances vous savez pertinemment
qu'en proposant une charge de 15
milliards d'euros supplémentaires par an
votre proposition nous paraît
tyroscevable et nous paraît aussi un
constitutionnel comme l'a dit madame la
Première ministre allez vous augmentez
les cotisations de 1000 euros par an sur
tous les Français allez-vous diminuer
les pensions de retraite allez vous
sabrer dans les budgets de l'éducation
nationale de la transition écologique ou
la sécurité comment monsieur de Courson
allez-vous financer ces 15 milliards il
y a une chose de sûr il a mis une seule
réalité c'est que vous ne pourrez plus
jamais monsieur le député venir dans
cette hémistique et doctement faire la
leçon sur les finances publiques
aujourd'hui avec votre proposition de
loi si d'aventure elle était adoptée
vous mettez un mâle et vous mettez en
danger le système de répartition vous
dégradez les finances publiques et vous
tournez le dos à tout esprit de
responsabilité seul député de Courson
comment vous sentez-vous comment vous
sentez-vous car le Front National et les
filles se lèvent où vous soutenir dans
une
admirable tonalité
[Applaudissements]